يقول إيلون ماسك إن أسعار سيارات تسلا
آخذة في الارتفاع
بسبب ضغوط سلسلة التوريد.
على تويتر
ردًا على تغريدة
تشكو من ارتفاع الأسعار ، نعم جوليا
دائمًا ابحث عن الأخبار في ردود إيلون مسك
على التغريدات وليس فقط تغريداته الخاصة ،
وهذا وفقًا لـ dan ives at webbush هو
الزيادة التدريجية السابعة
في سعر الموديل 3 و y  على مدار
الأشهر القليلة الماضية ، لذا فهي
مهمة وتيسلا كما نعلم ليست
محصنة ضد مشكلات سلسلة التوريد التي
رأيناها
تؤثر على جميع الكارما لأن هذا ما
تعرفه يجب أن يقوله في تغريدته ، قال إن
السعر يرتفع
بسبب سعر سلسلة التوريد الرئيسية  ضغط
المواد الخام على مستوى الصناعة ، خاصةً أننا نعرف أشياء
مثل الألومنيوم والنحاس والألومنيوم ، كل
تلك الأشياء الضرورية لتصنيع السيارات
قد ارتفعت بشكل صادم في pri  ce
وفقًا للشركات التي
تحدثت إليها وفي نفس الوقت
نشهد نقصًا
في الرقائق الدقيقة أيضًا بسبب مشكلات سلسلة التوريد
التي أدت إلى انقطاع
الإنتاج ،
وقد أدت مشكلات سعة الميناء إلى
ارتفاع التكاليف المعجلة التي تعلمناها كل
هذا
في أحدث مكالمة أرباح من تسلا
وزيادات السعر التي تعرفها كانت
كبيرة إلى حد ما ، أنت تعلم أنني أنظر
إلى أرشيف الإنترنت
في فبراير ، كان النطاق القياسي للنموذج
3 29000.
الآن يبلغ حوالي 33 ونصف ألف ، لذلك
هذا موجود
حقًا  زيادة سعرية بمقدار 15 على هذا الأمر
المهم إلى حد ما ، ومرة أخرى يل
ي تسلا باللوم على المواد الخام التي فعلوها على ال
غم من أنهم قالوا في مكالمة الأرباح الأخيرة أن
لوضع يبدو أنه يت
سن ، وكان لديك صدمة أي
ًا إذا كنت قد دفعت في  Bitc
ثم استرداد الأموال في غضون ذلك أيضًا ،
ولكن هذه نقطة منفصلة تمامًا ،
إنها دائمًا ما تجعلني أضحك عندما
نتحدث عن tesla
مهما كانت القصة بسببها بالطبع
إنهم لا يدفعون أي نفقات إعلانية أو
تسويقية
لأننا في نهاية المطاف نقوم بذلك
نيابة عنهم ومن الواضح أن elon musk يفعل ذلك
بنفسه ولكن
ما نسمعه من صانعي السيارات الآخرين
ربما عن ارتفاع الأسعار
جيدًا نعلم جيدًا أن الأسعار ترتفع
هناك ومرة أخرى  هذا
ما تحدثنا عنه عندما تحدثنا عن
التضخم ، وتقاطع استدعاء
تعطل سلسلة التوريد
والطلب المتزايد ، نعلم أن
الطلب على السيارات الجديدة قد ارتفع
بشكل كبير ، وسيعود الناس إلى
العمل الذي يحتاجون إليه من أجل
لا يزال الناس قلقون بعض الشيء من وسائل
النقل العام أه أشياء من هذا القبيل ، لذا تقول جي دي
باور في الربع الأول
أن أسعار السيارات الجديدة في الولايات المتحدة ارتفعت
بنسبة ثمانية بالمائة إلى
3337200 ، كما أنها تؤثر أيضًا على السيارات المستعملة
بشكل كبير وقد ارتفعت هذه الأسعار
في المزاد
يبدو أن 26 منذ بداية العام
ارتفعت مبيعات التجزئة بنسبة سبعة في المائة ، لكنني أعلم
من التحدث
إلى تجار السيارات أنهم يرفعون أيضًا
الأسعار التي يقولون
أه بنحو 20 ، لذا  nch
في هذه الصناعة في الوقت الحالي ، تجدر
الإشارة إلى أنه عند المقارنة مع تسلا ،
فإن شراء سيارة تسلا يختلف
قليلاً عن شراء نوع آخر من السيارات في كثير من الأحيان
مع أنواع أخرى من السيارات ، يمكنك المساومة على
تسلا يميل إلى عدم السماح
لك بدفع سعر الملصق لذلك  هذا هو السبب في أن
هذه الزيادات في الأسعار كبيرة هناك